[Musik]
ja meine damen und herren nachdem ich
mich schon per podcast zurückgemeldet
hatte wollte ich mich heute auch noch
mal in form des gesichtes und einer
presse-konferenz oder mindestens eines
statements mit fragen zurückmelden und
vom corona kabinetts berichten aber auch
von dem was in europa diskutiert wird
wir hatten heute die la corona kabinett
wie sie wissen und sind ja auch schon
informiert worden von den entsprechenden
fachministern es waren glaube ich
wichtige beschlüsse einmal zu der
tatsache dass wir auch nationale
beziehungsweise mit europa abgestimmte
wege gehen wollen wenn es um
schutzausrüstungen persönliche
schutzausrüstung geht hier insbesondere
auch die produktion von masken
ich glaube bei aller tatsache dass
dieser markt jetzt im augenblick in
asien angesiedelt ist ist es doch auch
wichtig dass wir als eine erfahrung aus
dieser pandemie lernen dass wir hier
auch eine gewisse souveränität brauchen
oder zumindest eine säule der
eigenfertigung das kann in deutschland
sein wir werden es aber auch europaweit
versuchen abzustimmen auf jeden fall
brauchen wir hier fähigkeiten an einem
zweiten punkt ging es um einreise nach
deutschland sie wüssten haben wir
verfolgt dass wir in der letzten woche
bereits mit dem robert-koch-institut
abgestimmte regelungen für den
aufenthalt von saison arbeitern in
deutschland festgelegt haben und jetzt
geht es noch einmal darum dass wir den
freien reiseverkehr der berufspendler
und er beruflich unterwegs seinen
garantieren und trotzdem bei den vielen
die vielleicht auch nach deutschland
zurückkehren maximalen gesundheitsschutz
veranlassen hier werden wir im laufe
dieser woche zusammen mit den ländern
den deren hoheit dass auch liegt
dann die entsprechenden beschlüsse
fassen wir müssen dass es deshalb auch
tun weil das robert koch institut in
zukunft nicht mehr einzelne
risikogebiete ausweisen wird sondern
weil das robert koch institut inzwischen
der meinung ist dass cola virus in 180
190 ländern aufgetreten ist dass wir
hier doch die welt als ein risikogebiet
haben und deshalb werden solche
einreisebeschränkungen das heißt die
verhängung von häuslicher quarantäne
dann auch notwendig sein für diejenigen
die nach deutschland kommen egal woher
sie kommen mit ausnahme derer zu machen
was ja auch zwischen deutschland und
frankreich und anderen ländern die als
berufspendler unterwegs sind wir haben
uns auch damit auseinandergesetzt wie
jetzt der beschaffungs starb im
gesundheitsministerium der eingerichtet
wurde arbeitet und die versorgung der
betroffenen personengruppen mit masken
gewährleistet hier sind wir
vorangekommen aber noch nicht so wie wir
es uns wünschen dass heißt wir müssen
hart arbeiten damit krankenhäuser ärzte
pflegeeinrichtungen
behinderteneinrichtungen damit das
personal dort wirklich ausreichend und
auch nicht von tag zu tag lebend mit den
entsprechenden schutz gütern
ausgestattet ist und als vierten punkt
haben wir eine modifikation des schon
bestehenden kfw-programms also des
programms der kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau zur vergabe von darlehen
darlehen verabschiedet das war deshalb
notwendig weil das von uns zuerst
aufgelegte programm nur eine 90
prozentige garantie absicherung für die
unternehmen gegeben hat und es hat sich
herausgestellt dass es sehr sehr
schwerfällig für viele unternehmen ist
wenn banken dann eine prognose für die
fortführung des unternehmens abgeben
müssen
deshalb haben wir uns entschieden und
das ist ja im grundsatz auch von der eu
kommission gebilligt worden dass es eine
haftungsfreistellung in höhe von 100
prozent geben kann die minister scholz
und altmaier haben sie ja auch darüber
informiert bis zu drei monatsumsätzen
bis zu 800.000 euro darlehen
bei bis zu 50 beschäftigten dann 500.000
es sind sicherungen natürlich eingebaut
dass das eher unternehmen bereits seit 1
1 2009 10 am markt sein muss dass
gewinne erwirtschaftet haben muss und
die zinssätze werden auch etwas höher
sein als die bei dem ersten kfw
kreditprogramm das alles sind wichtige
maßnahmen wir werden dann am donnerstag
in corona kabinett der den punkt eigenen
herstellung von persönlicher
schutzausrüstung noch einmal etwas
komprimierter und umfassender
beratschlagen
wir haben gesagt das soll das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium also peter
altmaier verantwortlich zeichnen dafür
wird auch ein stab eingerichtet der sich
nur mit dieser frage von nationaler
beziehungsweise europaweiter produktion
beschäftigen wird so dass wir dann auch
einen festen zugang zu den ausrüstungen
haben sie wissen dass morgen die
euro-gruppe takt oder besser gesagt mit
einer video-konferenz zusammentritt und
wir haben ja als europäischer rat in der
vergangenen woche der euro gruppe den
auftrag gegeben vorschläge vorzulegen
wie wir der krise begegnen können
ich will hier an dieser stelle sagen
dass aus meiner sicht europa die
europäische union vor der größten
bewährungsprobe seit ihrer gründung
steht das unbenommen wir haben eine
große herausforderung für die gesundheit
unserer bevölkerung alle mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union wenn auch in
abgestufter weise so sind alle betroffen
ist ist eine ein symmetrischer schock
wie man das etwas technisch bezeichnet
das heißt alle sind davon gleichermaßen
betroffen und deshalb muss es auch das
interesse aller sein und das ist das
interesse deutschlands dass europa stark
aus dieser bewährungsprobe hervorgeht es
geht dabei darum zu verstehen dass auch
deutschland und das habe ich immer und
immer wieder gesagt auch bei
vorhergehenden krisen und diesmal gilt
es noch mehr auch deutschland wird es
auf dauer nur gut gehen wenn es europa
gut geht und wir erleben jetzt ja auch
wenn wir uns einfach nur mal angucken
wir unsere wirtschaften verflochten
was passiert wenn der freie dank der
güter nicht gewährleistet ist
deshalb kann die antwort nur heißen mehr
europa ein stärkeres europa und ein gut
funktionierendes europa und zwar in
allen seinen teilen das heißt in allen
seinen mitgliedsstaaten und natürlich
sind in besonderer weise die länder
betroffen die rund noch einmal verstärkt
verbunden sind durch eine gemeinsame
währung die soll eine weltweit starke
währung sein und deshalb haben wir auch
die finanzminister um vorschläge gebeten
der bundesfinanzminister hat ihnen schon
gesagt und welche drei elemente ist im
augenblick in der diskussion geht es
geht einmal um das kriseninstrument
europäischer stabilitätsmechanismus esm
hier gibt es vorsorgliche kreditlinien
die auch mit einer geringeren
konditionalität ausgestattet sind
die es ermöglichen sicherheit für alle
zu schaffen
es gibt die möglichkeit der europäischen
verträge
im falle von naturkatastrophen so ist
zum artikel 122 der eu-verträge
festgelegt besondere maßnahmen zu
ergreifen und ich glaube wir können
sagen dass die pandemie corona pandemie
etwas ist was einer naturkatastrophe
gleichkommt und insofern kann die
europäische kommission hier darlehen
vergeben an die mitgliedstaaten und ich
finde den vorschlag von ursula von der
leyen sehr begrüßenswert dass man
insbesondere im bereich der sicherung
von arbeitsplätzen das heißt von
arbeitsmarktpolitischen instrumenten wie
zum beispiel dem kurzarbeitergeld hier
eine große europäische kraftanstrengung
startet wir als bundesrepublik
deutschland haben mit dem
kurzarbeitergeld sehr gute erfahrungen
gemacht nicht alle können das in
gleichem maße im augenblick tun und
deshalb das angebot bis zu einer höhe
von 100 milliarden euro
da müsste deutschland 7 milliarden euro
sozusagen garantien geben ein solches
instrument zur verfügung zu stellen
damit arbeitsplätze durch diesen schock
der im wirtschaftlichen bereich
stattfindet nicht verloren gehen es wird
also darum gehen zu zeigen
dass wir bereit sind unser europa zu
verteidigen es zu stärken wir werden
natürlich dann ein wiederbelebungs
programm ein wiederaufbauprogramm nach
diesem schweren wirtschaftlichen
einschnitt brauchen nicht nur jeweils in
den nationalstaaten sondern auch
europäisch auch da ist deutschland
bereit seinen beitrag zu leisten und wir
werden eine diskussion haben über die
frage welche strategischen fähigkeiten
müssen wir in europa haben wollen wir in
europa haben und diese dann ganz gezielt
aufzubauen gleichzeitig die
digitalisierung voranzutreiben und im
blick auf den klimaschutz der ja als
thema nicht verloren gegangen ist das
richtige zu tun dass würden dann die
entscheidung sein wenn wir die
schwersten teile dieser krise im
gesundheitlichen bereich erst einmal
überstanden haben
das sind die dinge die mir wichtig sind
im zusammenhang mit der tagung der
finanzminister der euro-gruppe morgen
und das werden wir sicherlich auch im
europäischen rat ist dann demnächst
wieder diskutieren ein termin dafür
steht noch nicht fest das denkt jetzt
auch von den beratungen der
finanzminister ab das war es was ich
ihnen sagen wollte und jetzt bitte ich
um ihre fragen
frau bundeskanzlerin die grenzkontrollen
zwischen bayern und österreich wenn
anders aussehen als zwischen nordrhein
westfalen und den niederlanden liegt das
an den ministerpräsidenten oder was ist
der unterschied
na ja wir haben zum teil wünsche der
ministerpräsidenten gehabt
das galt für bayern da waren die
grenzkontrollen ja schon im bestehend
aus anderen gründen aber auch baden
württemberg und das saarland und
rheinland pfalz hatten darum gebeten zu
einem zeitpunkt als die verhängten
maßnahmen zwischen deutschland und
frankreich noch recht unterschiedlich
waren im augenblick ist es ja so dass es
da auch eine hohe angleichung gegeben
hat während nordrhein westfalen und
niedersachsen einen anderen weg gewählt
haben sie haben eine sehr sehr enge
abstimmung zwischen den niederlanden und
auch belgien und nordrhein westfalen und
im falle von niederlanden auch
niedersachsen gehabt und haben darum
gebeten auch sich den verkehr anschauen
dass dieses grenzmanagement jetzt so
beibehalten werden kann und dass im
zweifelsfall eine verstärkte
steuerfahndung durch die bundespolizei
noch stattfindet man glaubt aber dass
sich der verkehr dort wirklich auf die
pendler beschränkt es ist ein sehr
intensiver austausch an diesen grenzen
und deshalb haben wir gesagt wir glauben
dass wir damit auch das notwendige
erreichen können das ist jedenfalls der
stand jetzt
frau merkel eine frage ganz kurz vorweg
zu den berliner vorkommnisse bewerten
sie denn die aussagen des berliner
regierenden bürgermeisters dass das
verhalten der usa im fall der angeblich
abhanden gekommenen machten unmenschlich
sei die linien dazu nähere informationen
vor die eine solche äußerung
rechtfertigen würden und dann die zweite
frage betrifft die frage eines
ausstiegsszenarios aus dem lot down da
gibt es ein papier aus dem
bundesinnenministerium das auch die
runde macht dass auch bekannt ist dazu
dann die für dann die frage was halten
sie von dem papier da ist von corona
hotels die rede und auch davon dass man
eine zentrale kommunikations stelle
einrichten so eine art corona
beauftragten im bundeskanzleramt ist das
geplant und österreich hat ja jetzt
schon leichte lockerungen angekündigt
also erstmal zu dem was sie zu berlin
gefragt haben mir liegen darüber keine
näheren informationen vor ich finde es
wichtig dass das jetzt auch aufgeklärt
wird auch das habe ich aus dem berliner
senat gehört wir wissen dass das
unternehmen sagt dass sie sich das nicht
vorstellen können wir haben sehr
unterschiedliche äußerungen und ich
hoffe dass man das wirklich aufklären
kann und denke dass das auch möglich ist
dass weiter ich habe schon am wochenende
in meinem podcast gesagt wir werden ja
eine schlechte bundesregierung wenn wir
nicht intensiv ich sagte sogar tag und
nacht darüber nachdenken würden wie wir
auch bei einhaltung des
gesundheitsschutzes das leben wieder
schrittweise öffnen können ich wäre aber
auch eine schlechte bundeskanzlerin oder
während werden eine schlechte
bundesregierung wenn wir jetzt schon ein
datum nennen würden das können wir nicht
wir haben erste andeutungen wie sich die
dinge entwickeln österreich war uns
immer ein stück voraus in den
gingen aber müssen unsere eigenen zahlen
ansetzen und deshalb ist es auf jeden
fall jetzt nicht geraten über ein datum
in deutschland zu sprechen
ich sage mit bedacht dass der
gesundheitsschutz auch bei eröffnung des
öffentlichen lebens immer im vordergrund
stehen wird und dass die frage wie es
weitergeht auf jeden fall oder über der
überschrift laufen wird wir leben weiter
in der pandemie das virus wird nicht
verschwunden sein so mehr kann ich dazu
heute nicht sagen natürlich denken
darüber nach natürlich gibt es studien
sie es gibt die aus dem innenministerium
es gibt von herrn fuchs und frau wochen
eine studie
ich selber habe freue mich dass die
leopoldina einer arbeit macht die auch
dann kurz nach ostern erscheinen wird
die sich genau mit demselben thema
beschäftigt und da müssen natürlich
mediziner soziologen und ökonomen
zusammenarbeiten welche schlüssel wird
daraus ziehen können wir ihnen aber
heute noch nicht sagen aber nachdenken
tun wir und auf jeden fall wird es ein
schrittweises vorgehen seien so viel
kann man auch schon sagen ach so wir
haben jetzt zu der struktur wie wir dann
vorgehen noch keine entscheidungen
getroffen das wird dann alles zum
rechten zeitpunkt gemacht werden da gibt
es viele vorschläge jetzt ist wir sind
ja nicht die einzigen die sich darüber
gedanken machen sondern viele andere
auch aber es wird zum schluss immer
darauf ankommen dass wir bei aller
notwendigkeit des wirtschaftlichen
handelns den gesundheitsschutz vorne
anstellen denn so wie viele sich
wünschen dass es jetzt schnell
vorangehen möchte
so wird die diskussion wenn die ersten
menschen sterben weil wir zu schnell
gehandelt haben und unser
gesundheitssystem den belastungen nicht
mehr standhalten wird sich sofort ins
gegenteil verkehren
und das wäre ganz schlecht wir würden zu
schnell voranschreiten um dann sozusagen
wieder alles zurücknehmen zu müssen das
versuchen wir zu vermeiden immer bei der
maßgabe nicht unser gesundheitssystem zu
überlassen
und ich will an der stelle auch noch mal
sagen dass ich sehr dankbar bin
dass sich so viele menschen darauf auch
ein lassen diese sehr sehr harten regeln
gerade wenn man sich das wetter anschaut
wie es jetzt im augenblick ist
einzuhalten weil sie wissen dass sie
damit einen beitrag leisten
menschenleben zu retten zu sichern und
auch krankenschwestern ärzten und allen
die im gesundheitssystem tätig sind
wirklich das leben etwas leichter bei
aller belastung zu machen und für dieses
verständnis dass es gibt möchte ich mich
bedanken denn die regeln werden jedoch
von der überwiegenden mehrzahl der
menschen
frau bundeskanzlerin meine frage nochmal
zu dem thema lockerungen der maßnahmen
ihr aktuelles kriterium dafür lautet wie
genau sie haben gesagt die verdopplung
zeit der infektionen ist entscheidend
erst hieß es zehn tage dann zwölf jetzt
vielleicht sogar 14
wenn sie noch mal sagen können was genau
ist die aktuelles kriterium und gibt es
weitere kriterien für eine mögliche
lockerung der maßnahmen und der zweite
kurze frage zum thema masken die
leopoldina diese jagd auch gerade
erwähnt haben empfiehlt ja am freitag
eine mundschutz mund und nasenschutz
pflicht für die gesamte bevölkerung mit
einfachen masken warum zögern sie da
bist du ja so eine einfache pflicht
ausgerufen
also erstens sind wir noch in der phase
wo wir uns auch die ratschläge der
experten immer wieder anhören und ich
sage mal am anfang gab es mehr
zurückhaltung zu diesen masken zu den
alltags masken wenn ich das mal so sagen
darf jetzt wandelt sich auch die meinung
der experten und der werden wir uns
natürlich nicht entgegenstellen
allerdings sagen uns alle experten eine
gut gehandhabt maske das heißt
regelmäßiges waschen nicht zu lange
tragen heiß bügeln oder im backofen oder
mikrowelle stecken ist die voraussetzung
dafür dass die begrenzte wirkung aber
wenigstens die begrenzte wirkung auch
eintritt unsachgemäßer umgang wäre noch
fataler und auf jeden fall heißt es
dabei nie die abstandsregeln vergessen
wer also glaubt
wir brauchen nicht mehr 1 5 bis zwei
meter abstand zu halten weil er eine
solche alltags marge beträgt das wäre
falsch absolut falsch aber wenn sich das
jetzt immer weiter durchsetzt dann wären
wir natürlich auch dafür plädieren dass
menschen das tun wie weit wir was mit
welchen begleiterscheinungen verbinden
das wird sich dann im zusammenhang mit
der aussage zu möglichen lockerungen
ergeben das ist heute nicht der tag aber
ich verfolge die diskussion in der
fachwelt sehr aufmerksam
wir wissen ja auch dass deutsche
unternehmen jetzt beginnen solche masken
zu produzieren und viele auch in
eigenarbeit das tun soweit ich das
verstanden habe muss der stoff möglichst
fest sein damit es auch seine wirkung
entfaltet aber die pflege dieser masken
ist dann auch ganz ganz wichtig und die
ja das kriterium also die verschiebung
der zahlen hatte jetzt etwas damit zu
tun dass wir im laufe der
krankheitsverläufe gesehen haben dass
die beatmung auch abhängig vom alter der
patienten länger dauert als wir das am
anfang erwartet hatten das hat auch
damit zu tun dass am anfang bei uns sehr
viele menschen als jüngere menschen
infiziert waren
es gibt im grunde kriterien die alle
miteinander zusammenhängen in einer
größeren deutschen tageszeitung gibt es
dazu heute in sehr guten artikel
das ist einmal dieser reproduktions
faktor 0
das ist dann auf der anderen seite die
frage der verdopplung die hat etwas zu
tun mit der überbelastung des
gesundheitswesens es gibt auch die frage
habe ich eine stabile zahl von
neuerkrankungen und ist vielleicht die
zahl derer die jeden tag gesunden
ähnlich hoch wie der der neu erkranken
oder ist sie jedenfalls in einem
bestimmten verhältnis zueinander
wir werden das zum schluss nicht
abschließend sagen können und ich
vermute mal die virologen werden uns
auch nicht sagen können ihr könnt diese
und jene und noch eine maßnahme machen
das geht gar nicht sondern wir müssen
dann auch gucken was wirkt wie und das
ist nicht ganz so einfach das
herauszufinden auf jeden fall muss jede
frage so
gestaltet werden dass wir immer wieder
gucken können wird unser
gesundheitssystem überfordert oder nicht
dann der gesundheitsschutz steht an
oberster stelle
aber an den tagen sehen wir ja zum
beispiel und das sagen uns die leute die
sich auf den produktionsfaktor verlassen
genauso oder auf die neue fall die neue
fallzahl da sehen wir dass wir einen
schritt vorangekommen sind aber ist es
immer noch nicht so dass man sagen
könnte wir können jetzt in irgendeiner
weise entwarnung geben sondern es ist
nicht der tag an dem wir bereits
aussagen treffen können das macht uns
auch kein virologen das heißt sie haben
jetzt erstmal bis zum einschließlich 19
april unsere maßnahmen getroffen
daran wird sich auch nichts ändern frau
bundeskanzlerin auch nochmal zum exit
aber auf der europäischen ebene bund und
länder mehr vereinbart nachdem einige
vorwürfe angebracht sind bei der
verschärfung von maßnahmen das man bei
der lockerung möglichst gemeinsam
handeln bild aber muss man das nicht
auch auf europäischer ebene tun
jetzt gibt es einige länder wie
österreich die schon anfangen aber das
könnte ja wieder neue grenzt debatten
hervorrufen wenn in einem land was
erlaubt wird was im anderen land nicht
erlaubt wird und eine kurze nachfrage zu
der heimischen produktion die sie
anfangs erwähnt haben
wenn jetzt hier in deutschland schon
garantien für abnahme von schutzmasken
zum beispiel bis ende 2 1 und 20 gegeben
werden wie will man dann noch eine
europäische koordinierung hinbekommen
weil doch moment auch da jedes land für
sich jetzt schon mit der wirtschaft
einzelne verträge schließt ja ich glaube
das ist schon richtig ist dass jedes
land für sich selber mal überlegt was
kann es leisten und dann wird man in
einen austausch treten und vielleicht
kann der eine das eine und der andere
das anderen dann kann man sicher darüber
auch austauschen
wichtig für die investoren ist ja nur
dass es eine abnahmegarantie gibt ob
hier die dann alle nehmen oder wir sie
mit einem anderen europäischen ländern
teilen die uns dafür wieder was anderes
geben das wird man dann ja sehen nur
dass man erst mal selber guckt welche
kapazitäten können wir aufbauen das
finde ich schon richtig
zweitens natürlich wird es bestimmte
prozesse zb das bauen von autos wird
überhaupt erst wieder gut funktionieren
wenn in italien in spanien in anderen
europäischen ländern auch
unternehmen wieder öffnen weil weil
ansonsten die wertschöpfungskette gar
nicht funktioniert aber ich glaube dass
wir was dass wir trotzdem auch
unterschiedliche gegebenheiten in europa
haben was den zustand der infektion also
auch die phase der infektion anbelangt
italien hat ja sehr viel früher mit den
maßnahmen begonnen ist in einigen
regionen aber auch sehr sehr hart
betroffen gewesen
das heißt dass wir überall sozusagen das
gleiche tun das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen
deshalb hat er die kommission auch genau
diese einschränkungen bei schengen
akzeptiert sie hat gesagt der freie
warenverkehr muss gewährleistet sein die
pendler sollen hin und her gehen können
aber der freie verkehr besuchs verkehr
sozusagen das der sofort wieder
eingeführt wird das kann man nicht
machen damit dazu bedürfte es dann der
lockerung überall und in gleichem maße
aber das ist nicht notwendig bei der
augenblicklichen regelung an den grenzen
glaube ich aber für bestimmte
wertschöpfungsketten ist das ganz
wichtig wir haben ja zum beispiel nie
durch allgemeinverfügung verboten das
automobil fabriken arbeiten
sie haben selber das arbeiten
eingestellt warum auf zwei gründen
einmal weil die autohändler geschlossen
hatten und damit auch keine autos mehr
verkauft werden können und zum anderen
weil sie die bestimmten teile überhaupt
nicht mehr bekommen haben die sie hätten
bekommen können weil in anderen ländern
bestimmte produktionskapazitäten nicht
mehr produziert haben
frau bundeskanzlerin es gibt inzwischen
befürchtungen dass die krisenregelung
und die einschränkungen für die bürger
nach der krise nicht mehr vollständig
zurückgefahren werden könnten
können sie die bürger beruhigen und
nochmal eine zusatzfrage habe ich das
richtig verstanden dass die position die
die minister mars und scholz in mehreren
europäischen zeitungen vertreten haben
nämlich dieser dreiklang von er ist im
ep und schuhe dass die gemeinsame
position der bundesregierung ist ich
spreche jeden tag mehrfach mit dem
bundesfinanzminister darüber wir agieren
ja in europa abgestimmt ich meine wir
haben der euro gruppe einen auftrag
gegeben oder eine bitte geäußert dass
wir uns vorschläge vorlegen
und bevor die deutsche position
festgelegt wird stimmen wir uns
natürlich ab und zwar sehr sehr eng
zweitens kann ich darf ich den
bürgerinnen natürlich sagen als auch
eine freiheitsliebende bürgerin im
dreißigsten jahr der deutschen einheit
sobald es die gesundheitliche situation
zulässt werden wir selbstverständlich
ist zudem freien leben wie wir es kennen
zurückkehren das ist kein regel loses
leben das wissen sie es gab immer schon
gesetze die man einhalten muss aber das
was wir hatten und oft das was wir stolz
waren das wollen wir natürlich wieder
erreichen dass das überhaupt gar keine
frage aber wir müssen immer im blick
darauf machen gefährden wir menschen das
ist die einzige grundlage warum wir
jetzt so handeln mussten und das fällt
ja auch niemandem leicht weil das fällt
den menschen die betroffen sind nicht
leicht aber glauben sie noch nicht dass
es mir als politikerin leicht fällt mit
anderen gemeinsam so etwas anordnen zu
müssen das ist doch etwas was wir uns
lieber erspart hätten aber was die
umstände einfach erfordert dankeschön